suchen sie etwas bestimmtes politisches
große show moderation gut ich verstehe
was für eine matratze suchen sie denn
kaltschaum latex federkern mit hoppe
ohne top
anders was für eine matratze haben sie
den bisher
richtig
so kommen wir nicht weiter wenn ich mir
so anschaue von der figur her eher
kräftig bis korpulent da brauchen wir
was gescheites die hier
die matratze lummerland eine
visco-schaum matratze mit atmungsaktiven
tappert die hochwertigste die wir da
haben aber es hängt natürlich auch von
ihren schlafgewohnheiten aber bitte
nicht hinsetzen ach so falch
entschuldigung
zurück
mussten rund 40
2080 euro
509 wenn sie eine günstige der matratze
haben möchte kann sich die vorschau
matratze wie anschauen da wende damit
1000 euro
diesmal nutzt er sie
gleich um
persönlich mit der
bitte nicht anfassen
federkern mittel hat 710 maximale punkt
elektrizität durch klingt gut wie nie
und was kostet
400 euro
so kriege schuster total volk schaut mit
dem trotzen geht wo es mir kraft für gar
nichts halt noch mit akkus mit meinem
bruder macht hinten auf das ist okay
resultiert